he's Adam Sandler The Sandman joining us
from Hawaii are you shooting a movie or
you on vacation hi Danny
yes I I'm sitting in in white man is
mowing the lawn
pretty close debate I'm trying to signal
keep it down but he won't listen okay
what are you doing yet in Hawaii David
Spade is making a movie we're producing
it family is here and life is life is
doing exceptionally well today you have
Duke winning at all how nervous were you
yesterday was Central Florida I was on
an airplane and I would ask what's going
on I couldn't get the internet because
when you try to Hawaii
it goes dead you know and it turned out
it was I thought it would be how about
you buy it with everybody baffled
a little bit because you kept thinking
well central when is Duke gonna start
acting like Duke and then you realized
they are acting like Duke it's just
Central Florida we didn't know about man
that's pretty cool and I was I was there
this year did it show earlier this year
everything wasn't about that team that's
pretty cool I'm happy they did so well
McLovin would you update Sandman and
where he stands in the celebrity bracket
ciao bye the way Jim Jim Parsons from
the Big Bang Theory is dominating right
now cinnamon I love it I'm disgusted
with myself but I did a I am a new girl
Jim yeah it's nice that he got a break
he doing it
no no but he's he's done pretty well
here he's he's kind of roughing us up
here and he said he doesn't really
follow college basketball that much but
I think the more you know the more you
know that the the worse you do in this
oh my god no I don't know that much but
I had a few hunches as I was sowing out
the black tie so why am i right
down right now I know this is not gonna
pay off and then it's a nice you know
whatever you use your heart you always
get smacked in that all right McLovin
what do you have okay
so Adam is middle of the pack which is a
good news the bad news is he's exactly
tied with David Spade wow that's gotta
hurt you know he probably she looked at
mine or something I don't know I'm
guessing something he didn't either
steal my stuff did he I don't think so
we we had to almost guilt him into doing
this cuz he'd said no I don't know
anything and I don't want to do it I
want a baby
if you lose this made Sandman yeah that
would be a no but David you know I know
I know I'm eating him later today when I
see when I throw him down I'll matter
what did you play any high school sport
yes I played bass at the bench at the
bench I was very slow but my um I played
guitar and my teeth my coach like that
so he would have me jam during the
basketball practices were you funny back
then you know I was pretty funny but you
know one make the team hated me most
Danny Boy when it was the last five
minutes of practice and they we would do
suicides and he said you got to finish
the suicide I don't know what's the 30
seconds or something you gotta finish
within 30 seconds or the whole team runs
again and I swear to God right before
just go seriously man pick it up yeah
you know I will I will
no no I'm serious pick it up don't make
me do that action and finally the coach
would be like I gotta go home okay so
I'm sorry guys and like stare at me I
swear to god outside by heart that I
can't can't give it like you guys what
was your high school best high school
basketball
none I mean I think I was like a roni
kind of guy I would come in towards the
end people would laugh at how high by
shorts or and I would I would tell
people a lot I think I think ever just
two or three files within two minutes
and people are like what is with this
idiot but I play now I like when I go on
the road and I get to play in the gym
sometimes I'll pull out playing like a
high school coach where you want to run
with the guys I'm I'm definitely I
definitely am I'm better than I used to
be yeah you are you can play I like
you're just you have an odd style about
you but you but you make it work I make
it work but I am so slow full quarters
rough and these guys just cruise up and
down the court you Danny have you played
full court recently no no no it's the
worst
everybody is so bad it runs up and down
in there back on D I every other play
fake something that makes me nervous
did you did you have a fro in high
school
of course I had a pic I had a fro I I
would never and never look that good I
never looked good ever I tried my best I
had a leather jacket the flow would lay
on the high collar my friends from
growing up would ask me to get a haircut
my father would say you look terrible
and I'd say I don't think you see what
I'm seeing
tells me we settle Oh have fun out there
in Hawaii and we'll about the middle of
the middle of the pack of it all I'm
sorry everybody but that's not over I
mean over salmon not over I'm in front
of you a little bit but and I'm doing
okay it's close okay all right good luck
to you keep here and love you thanks for
having me on night bud that's Adam
Sandler
he's got Duke over North Carolina to win
it all for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]